regiert hat er nie der Schröder regiert
jeden Tag das ist ja das furchtbare wenn sie
bei Schröder wenn sie da mitreen wollen dann
dürfen Sie kein einziges Interview verpassen
wenn jemand fragt sagen Sie mal was hatten
sie von dem was Schröder gestern wieder zur
Gesundheitspolitik gesagt hat und sie fragen
nicht sofort zurück meen sie das Interview
um 3 oder das um 3:30r eine halbe Stunde das
ist bei dem Tempo in demem Gerhard Schröder
dazu lernt ein kleines Universum das heißt der
Mann habe keine Visionen ist auch Quatsch der
hat die sogar alle verwirklicht Schröder ist
Kanzler mehr hat er nie gewollt seitem ist er
gut drauf super Job macht Spaß der fühlt
sich doch wie Slatko persönlich er speist
sein selbstbewusin aus der gleichen Quelle das
ist die neue Mode in Deutschland ich nenne das
die Arroganz der Debilität je blöder sie
sind desto schneller werden sie Kult in
diesem Land den Schröder können Sie mit Eiern
beschmeißen der wird da stehen mehr [Applaus]
mehr für den Schröder sind
das alles Zuwendungen das sind
Sachspenden der kommt aus ganz kleine
Verhältniss in der Schröder die waren
ja wirklich arm als er Kind war ja da
erzählt auch gerne von die waren richtig
Arm jetzt ist er Kanzler er ist selig
und diese ganze Spannbreite von Arm bis
seelig das verkörpert er die die CDU hat
das Privatfernsehen gegen den Willen der
Sozialdemokraten durchgesetzt und der Schröder
ist der erste der kapierter wie er mit dem Medium
umgeht der ist voll privat Fernseh kompatibel
immer fröhlich immer freundlich ne der schäel
wird da immer so mürrisch die Merkel auch die hat
sowas patziges hat sich beim schel abgeguckt g
typische Merkel und schpel Antwort wenn Sie nicht
weiter wissen diese Frage stellt sich für mich
nicht was denn das für eine Antwort sagen sie
man ja probieren Sie das mal bei der nächsten
Alkoholkontrolle der Schröder ist ganz anders der
ist immer freundlich der ist immer juvial und den
Schröder hat man so brutal interviewt wie noch
nie einen Kanzler vor ihm her Schröder was ist los
he darst morgen das haben sie überhaupt ein Plan
oder interessiert Sie nur wo die nächste kuhiber
herkommt dann bleibt der Schröder freundlich
dann sagt der Schröder das war aber jetzt eine
[Applaus] Fangfrage sind sie mal nun nehme ich mir
extra die Zeit um hier mit ihnen von der Presse
mal Ruh ein bisschen zu plaudern die doris hat
vorhin noch gesagt Gert musste du wirklich schon
wieder weg aber als ich hier gesagt habe dass
ich mich mit Ihnen hier treffe da hat sie mir
doch extra noch die Dose mit dem Plätzchen
mitgegeben die wir vorhin h verteilt haben
ich hoffe Sie haben alle was abbekommen also
wenn Sie Beschwerden wegen der Plätzchen haben
sagen Sie das ruhig die doris hat das Rezept zum
ersten Mal ausprobiert das können wir nachbessern
wir wollen ja dass sie sich alle wohlfühlen bei
der Presse sie haben ja nur auch einen schweren
Job sie müssen ja auch jeden Tag eine Zeitung
vollschreiben so wer hat denn noch eine Frage
so Schröder das ist ein Macher wenn er sie in
Hemd anzieht da Krempel sich die Ärmel von selber
auf Medienzeitalter Dienstleistung das hat
der Schröder kombiniert der Schröder ist
als kanzlerdarsteller unser oberster Dienstleister
deshalb nimmt er nichts persönlich wenn den Leuten
etwas nicht gefällt was er gesagt hat er weiß
es geht nicht gegen ihn als Mensch es geht nur
um den Text den er aufgesagt hat da lässt er sich
was Neues schreiben was soll das denn rotgrün ist
eine interaktive Daily Soap mit kliffhänger und
Schröder ist der Topverkäufer das hat er gelernt
seine Ausbildung Hauptschule dann Ausbildung als
Verkäufer das ist Schröders primärszialisation das
kriegen sie nie wieder raus das ist diese pick und
Kloppenburg Herren oberbekleidungsmentalität das
sind Menschen die stehen vor erwachsenen Männern
mit viel zu kurzen Hosen und sagen sie können das
Tragen